Good morning Hank, it's Monday.
Special bonus video!
I am in my home -- actually, I won't be in
my home by the time you watch this but I am
right now.
It feels so good to be home with my family
and my 2011 FA cup championship trophy...
and my fox hat and my copy of An Imperial
Affliction that Hazel read in the TFIOS movie
- it's not a real book, it's just a prop,
it's the same four pages I wrote over and
over and over again.
But mostly my family.
It's just very nice to be home for a couple
of days.
In other news the Project for Awesome starts
in five days, and Hank I want to make sure
that everyone in Nerdfighteria is ready, hence
the bonus video.
First, quick overview for new nerdfighters:
the Project for Awesome is that annual 48-hour
event where we raise lots of money for charity
and also lots of people make videos about
charity.
By the way, if you're going to make a Project
for Awesome video, I highly suggest you watch
this tutorial by Hank, about how to make a
great P4A video.
As Hank points out, one of the ways of imagining
a good Project for Awesome video is that it's
a kind of advertisement for the charity you're
trying to get people to vote for at projectforawesome.com.
If you're not going to make a Project for
Awesome video, that's OK there are still tons
of ways to participate!
You can watch and share Project for Awesome
videos and the Project for Awesome livestream
and of course you can vote for the charities
you want the donated money to go to at projectforawesome.com.
Also, if you can afford it, I hope you'll
consider donating via the Project for Awesome
IndieGoGo where there will be some pretty
awesome perks.
I want to thank everybody who's donated their
time and effort on this front from Natalie
Tran to Troye Sivan to all the nerdfighters
who made the nerdfighter art perks, like these
amazing French the Llama paintings.
There will be a lot of one-of-a-kind perks
that you've never been able to get before
and will never be able to get again, but more
on that once the IndieGoGo starts.
And lastly, how to divide up the money.
So Hank, we asked for nerdfighteria's thoughts
on this a few weeks ago.
The biggest concern that we heard was making
sure that the Project for Awesome can still
be a place where small charities get important
funding.
So here's what we're going to try this year.
If you donate on or before Day 1 of the Project
for Awesome, your money will be split between
Save the Children and Partners in Health,
two charities that nerdfighteria has worked
with a lot for many years.
They're both rated extremely highly by sites
that measure charity efficacy, and they both
have great reputations around the world for
doing good and efficient work to address poverty
and disease.
So this will allow us to decrease world suck;
also, it will allow us to at least, like,
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
matching donations, which is very good.
However, we're going to save a lot of the
perks for Day 2 and after of the fundraiser,
because that money will be split among charities
chosen by nerdfighteria, which, if history
is any indication, many of which will be small
and will do a wide variety of kinds of world
suck decreasing.
Again, those charities will be chosen by your
votes at projectforawesome.com, so vote carefully
and thoughtfully, so everyone can give however
they would prefer; I'm going to probably give
both ways.
You can do that too.
I know this seems like a huge info dump and
I haven't even talked about the fact that
there's gonna be a 48-hour livestream that
never stops and is gonna be tons and tons
of fun, featuring lots of your favorite YouTubers.
It's gonna be fun, if you're gonna make a
video upload it noon Eastern Time on Friday.
Hank, in the meantime you will actually see
me again tomorrow.
Hank, don't forget to be awesome.